[Musik]
dieser job interessant macht das so
viele verschiedene
ausbildungsmöglichkeiten die und dass
der dienstherr flexibel ist und kein tag
wie der andere eigentlich ist die
zusammenarbeit im team funktioniert
einwandfrei
dadurch dass wir gemeinsam gespielt
worden sind und gemeinsam die ausbildung
gemacht haben und das überträgt sich
dann auch immer auf die internationalen
teile ob im eigenen land oder
international
ihr habt mittlerweile so ein
ausgezeichneter ruf und warum das so ist
weiß ich ja mittlerweile aus eigener
erfahrung ich habe ja bei euch einen tag
einstellen dürften bei tagwache mit
rache dafür danke nochmal grundsätzlich
auch alle kameradinnen und kameraden
auch an die kameraden die dafür gesorgt
hat dass heute noch wenn praktiker mit
mir über diese wunderschöne erfahrung
redet nach und ganz im ernst also was
wir mittlerweile im land und
international leistet das ist einfach
nur veränderungen also keine revolution